[Music]
[Narrator:] Many people gave their time to help tell this story.
People from [?] and Gainesville.
People like Boyce Brown, young chicken farmer who plays John,
and Marjorie Morris who takes the part of his wife, Liza.
Mr. and Mrs. Jarrett play Liza's father and mother,
and Paula Haygood plays Nell.
[Music]
[Produced by Southern Educational Film Production Service, Athens, Georgia]
[Script by......George C. Stoney, Photography
by..Ralph A. Woolsey, Sound by.........Bill Godsey,
Music Director...Louis Applebaum, Music
by.......Lan Adomian, Edited by........Fred Lasse,
Assistant Editor..Barbara Clements, Assistant
Cameraman..Bob Gordon, Assistant
Director..Speight Cooper, Associate
Producer..Ralph A. Woolsey, Sound System]
[Directed by Bill Clifford]
[Music]
[Jeremiah:] How many dead this time?
[John:] Five, six. Two more about gone.
[Jeremiah:] You checked the temperature [?]
[John:] Yes, I checked it.
[Jeremiah:] Did you check the water?
[John:] Yes, I checked that, too.
[Jeremiah:] Well, it's dry now. Valve is stuck.
I thought you fixed it.
[Music]
[John:] Hey honey!
[Patsy:] Hi!.
[John:] What you got there?
[Patsy:] A boat.
[John:] Where'd you get it?
[Patsy:] I rowed it.
[Liza:] Her grandfather brought it from town.
[Silence]
[John:] They're going to spoil that child rotten if they keep that up.
[Liza:] No use your talking that way, John, and you know it.
If we've got to live together, they're bound to spoil her.
[John:] Yes, we'll keep on living here.
Doesn't your father decide how we're going to raise our children,
your mother decide how you're going to dress...then pretty soon well,
[Liza:] Hush up John, please.
You wanted to do business with daddy.
It was your idea to get all that money tied up, his life savings.
[John:] You act like I haven't got anything in it at all. Do all the work, building all the houses,
all the fetching and carrying.
[Mama:] Oh lordy, my biscuits!
[Liz:] I got them, mama.
[Mama:] Well they're ruined, totally ruined.
[Liza:] They're not burnt too bad to eat.
[Mama:] If more folks around here'd stay out of the kitchen and tend to their own work,
we'd be better off.
[John:] Well, I've been working over in that wind for the last five hours.
If a man can't stop for five minutes to get warm, then I don't know what.
[Mama:] Well, Jeremiah said you lost eight more chickens this afternoon,
and if keep that up John, you're gonna have us all in the poorhouse.
[John:] I lost them?
Guess he didn't have anything to do it.
Guess he didn't let that salesman talk him into buying untested chicks,
because they were two cents cheaper.
[Liza:] Hush up, John.
Mama, John has as much right to be in here as anybody.
[Mama:] Well, somebody's got to think about saving the two cents,
and Lord knows it wouldn't be you.
[John:] You call it saving.
I call it wasting.
[Jeremiah:] Young man.
I've been living on this farm for 30 years, before you ever came on with your big ideas
about chicken-raising, and I can do it again.
[John:] All right, all right, if that's the way you want it, I'll get out.
[Liza:] John, Papa didn't mean it that way.
[John:] Count on you to take sides against me, Liza.
[Liza:] John, wait.
[Music]
[Nell:] Can I help you?
[John:] Yeah, let me have a beer.
[Nell:] What kind?
[John:] Oh, any kind.
[Doug:] Hey John! Come on over.
[John:] Hi Doug!
[Doug:] How's the chicken farming?
[John:] Boy, you can have it! I wish I were back on the roads with you guys hauling the darn things.
You know there are more ways a fellow can lose his shirt raising chickens than you can imagine.
[Nell:] Is this where you want it?
[John:] Lordy, is everybody mad today?
[Nell:] I'm sorry, I had a bad day.
[John:] That's okay.
[Doug:] Say, that's not empty.
[Nell:] Look at that mess.
[Doug:] Watch out, Drake.
[John:] I'll help ya.
[Waiter:] The girl will get that up.
[John:] She might cut her hands.
[Nell:] Thanks for helping me.
[John:] That's okay.
[Music]
[Doug:] Drink up Ben, let's go.
Come on John, you gotta get going, too.
[John:] Ahh, I'm going to stick around a while.
[Nell wipes down the bar.]
[Nell:] Can't spend the night here, chicken farmer.
[John:] Okay, I'm going.
[Music]
[Nell:] How are you going to get home?
[John:] I got my truck over yonder.
[Nell:] You can't drive home like this.
[John:] I can't, huh?
[Nell:] No, you can't.
Come on, you better come over to my place and get some coffee and sober up.
[Nell:] Good night.
[John:] Good night.
[Footsteps walking away, then dramatic music]
[John:] You still up?
[Liza:] Yeah.
I wanted to get this dress finished. I can't get a thing done when mom's around.
She knows how to do some things better than I do, I guess, but she hasn't the least idea about style.
[John:] Aw, it's cold.
[Liza:] Don't you think it's going to look nice when I get it finished?
Look, John.
C'mon honey, don't be like that.
[Music]
[John:] Look at that, mama.
First week barefoot and they're tough as shoe leather already.
[Mama:] They sure are.
[John:] Go along then.
[Mama:] She's going to be a tough one to handle when the new baby comes.
[John:] I guess so, but I still don't see why Liza waited so long to tell me about that.
[Mama:] Ah, used to be a woman didn't tell her ole man 'til she couldn't hide it any more.
One time I kept my condition from Jeremiah almost four months.
You want a boy don't you? I never saw a man that didn't.
[John:] I guess I do, it's only natural, but shouldn't Liza be seeing a doctor?
[Liza:] What do I need a doctor to for?
I've got at least six and a half months to go yet and no doctor in the world can do anything about that.
[John:] I know that much honey, but haven't you got to be thinking about it?
[Liza:] Mama, I even showed him my maternity dress and he didn't even guess.
[Mama:] Well once they get ya married, a man don't take notice of anything, but John's right,
you should see Dr. Tidwell and make sure that everything's all right.
[Liza:] Oh, I'll go when the time comes, all right.
You two stop fussing at me.
[Mrs. McElvery:] You see Nell, we can cure you, but most people don't have to take examinations
like you food handlers do, and that means that anybody that you might have been with
in the past few months may have syphilis and not know it.
[Nell:] Yes ma'am.
[Mrs. McElvery:] And if they're married, they will probably make their wives sick with syphilis.
[Nell:] The way that no good husband of mine did before he ran off to Macon.
[Mrs. McElvery:] That's right Nell, but it can be even worse than that.
Suppose that this John that you told me about is married, and his wife should get pregnant.
Unless we find her soon and she takes treatment, it's very likely that her baby will be born dead or diseased.
[Nell:] I'll do anything you say to help, honest, but all I know is that the fellows
with him were teasing him about chickens and they called him John.
[Health worker:] Isn't there any way that you can get a message to him?
[Nell:] He hasn't been since that one night, but I've got to do something.
I wouldn't want anyone to get sick or die on account of me.
[Doctor:] Tall, dark-haired chicken farmer named John, I'm afraid...
[Mrs. McElvery:] You don't know if he's even from this county, doctor.
The girl wants to help all she can, I'm sure of that but we have so little to go on, and if he's married...
[Doctor:] And if his wife is pregnant that will make it all the worse.
[Music]
[John:] Cross your fingers honey.
Haven't lost but eight chicks out of this batch, and they're in the tenth week already.
[Liza:] You're going to make a chicken grower yet, with a few years of practice.
[John:] Hey! Take it easy honey.
[Music]
[Mama:] Lord have mercy, John the way you act, you'd think Liza's baby
was due tomorrow night.
A woman's gotta have some exercise.
[Jeremiah:] It's gonna be a boy ain't it, Liza.
[Mama:] Jeremiah Crawford, you'll wait five months to find out.
[Music]
[Waiter:] Anything else?
[Doug:] I guess that'll be all today.
[Nell:] Hey mister, pardon me.
Weren't you in here one night a couple of months ago?
[Doug:] Yeah, what about it?
[Nell:] You know the fellows that were with you, the one named John?
Do you know where I could find him?
[Doug:] Look little girl, if John wants to find you, he'll know where to come.
He's a married man you know.
[Waiter:] Come on Nell, let's wait on the tables.
[Nell:] I saw this other fellow, I'm sure he knows who he is and where he lives.
[Mrs. McElvery:] That may be Nell, but you see, this information that you gave us about John,
we have to keep in the strictest confidence, that's the law.
So you see we just can't go around asking everybody, even though you do know he's married.
[Nell:] But suppose his wife is, is going to have a baby.
[Mrs. McElvery:] That's the saddest thing of all.
If she is, let's hope to goodness she gets to a doctor right away.
[Nell:]  And everything will be all right.
[Mrs. McElvery:] If she gets treated in time.
You see Nell, in the first four months of pregnancy,
the disease does not get from the mother to the child.
In the fifth month and after it's very likely.
[Nell:] Then the baby will die?
[Mrs. McElvery:] No, there's a still chance to save it.
A great many women don't go to doctors until they've been pregnant for seven or even eight months,
and even then they don't take blood tests and no one knows until a baby comes
that anything is wrong.
[Nell:] I'll keep looking Mrs. McElvery.
[Mrs. McElvery:] Good girl. Bye.
[Nell:] Bye.
[Chicks chirping]
[John:] How many dead this morning?
[Jeremiah:] You know we've haven't lost but ten out of this pack yet.
Reckon you can raise boys as good as ten chickens.
[John:] Liza says it feels like twins, both of them girls.
[Music]
[John:] Hey honey! The load of feed I'm picking up this morning is gonna finish off this batch.
Ought to make $400 easy.
[Liza:] I want to see daddy's face when the check comes in.
[John:] Liza, why don't you come into town with me and see the doctor?
You're nearly five months gone.
[Liza:] Listen John, I feel perfectly all right.
I know when it's time to go to the doctor.
It isn't as though I haven't been through this before.
[John:] Okay, bye-bye.
[Music]
[Conference speaker:] The really important thing about this multiphase health testing program
that you civic leaders are helping to put on here in the county is just this:
Now for the first time, we'll be able to help a lot of our people who are walking around
with one or more of these diseases and don't know it. Some of them are right in your own organizations.
With one x-ray we can check for signs of
tuberculosis, and certain heart abnormalities.
With one sample of blood we can check for signs of anemia, diabetes, and syphilis.
And from a dental inspection, we can warn many of our people of oral cavities and of other oral defects.
[Woman 1:] Everything is strictly confidential.
Your tests are marked by a number and if they find anything that shows that you need
special treatment, you can go straight to your family doctor.
[Conference speaker 2:] And speaking for the county medical society, I wish to urge each and
every member of this organization to get behind this worthwhile project.
[Music]
[Man 2:] If everybody keep working like this, we'll test the county a hundred percent.
[Man 3:] That's the truth.
[Music]
[Woman:] Sorry.
[John:] That's okay.
[Music]
[John:] Hot enough for you?
[Woman:] I'll say, it's boiling.
[Music]
[Man 3:] Sounds like you're doing all right, John.
Folks usually have trouble the first batch or two.
Broilers are harder to raise than most folks think.
Are you going home now?
[John:] Yeah. You want a ride?
[Man 3:] I'd appreciate it.
My wife's helping with this big health program and I can't leave town before I go by
and get my checkup.
[John:] Okay, I'll wait for you.
[Man 3:] Thank you.
[Music]
[Nell:] Pardon me, is Miss McElvery in?
[Secretary:] No, she isn't. She's over across the square at the testing station.
Could somebody else help you?
[Nell:] No, no thank you. I'll go over there.
[Music]
[Man 3:] Won't you come on in with me?
[John:] No, I got a couple things I wanna do. I'll just wait.
[Man 3:] All right.
[Music]
[Nell:] John...
[Nurse 1:] What do you mean running off that way?
You come on in here and get yourself tested.
Where is Liza and all the family?
You should bring them all in and get them tested.
[Music]
[Barb:] Take this card over to the desk and she'll tell you what to do.
[Nurse 1:] I have another customer, Barb.
[Barb:] Your name, please.
[John:] John Lloyd.
[Barb:] Address.
[John:] Route 4, Madisonville District.
[Barb:] Married, Mr. Lloyd?
[John:] Yes.
[Barb:] Have you any children?
[John:] Yes, have one, going on two.
[Barb:] Good. Hope you'll have the whole family tested.
[John:] Reckon I will ma'am.
[Music]
[John:] Well doctor, what makes you so sure?
[Doctor:] Well, we can't be absolutely sure until the results of this second blood test
come back tomorrow, but your blood test did show a high titer.
[John:] Well, I haven't had any of these symptoms, except nausea and sore throat.
[Doctor:] Well that's just the trouble, Mr. Lloyd.
We're finding more and more cases like yours.
In the early infectious stages of disease, the symptoms are often so slight
that they go unnoticed.
By the way, I think when you come
tomorrow for the results on this second blood test,
you'd better bring Mrs. Lloyd in with you for the test.
[John:] But her, what's this got to do with her?
[Doctor:] Sit down, Mr. Lloyd.
We treat a lot of people in our VD clinics, Mr. Lloyd.
In fact, we have information that you've been exposed to an infectious case of syphilis.
Now only the two of us here in the clinic who have to do with treatment know this.
In fact, this is strictly confidential information.
I can't even tell you who gave us the information, but whoever did it, did you a real service.
In all probability you went through the infectious stages months ago,
and it's entirely possible that at that time wife was exposed.
[John:] But doctor she's pregnant, nearly five months I think.
[Doctor:] Then Good Lord man, you can't let her go another week without treatment,
while that baby is in danger of its life.
[John:] Why don't you go to the doctor, Liza?
[Liza:] But I told you John, I'll go see the doctor when it's time.
What's made you so worried all of a sudden?
[John:] It isn't all of a sudden.
I've been asking you and asking you and asking you.
Mama here can bear me out on that.
You act like I haven't got any right to take an interest in the child.
[Jeremiah:] [?] in my day the women called for the grandma...
[John:] You keep out of this, it's none of your business.
[Mama:] Everybody hush. Hush John.
Liza's a woman and she knows her time, no occasion for anyone else to be meddling in it.
[Music]
[John:] Liza. I lied to you this evening.
There is a reason why you've got to see a doctor.
[Liza:] Oh really?
[John:] They say I've, I've got syphilis and
if I've got it, then you've probably got it, too,
and if we don't do something quick the baby might be born blind or crippled or even dead.
[John:] Are you sure, doctor?
[Doctor:] There's no doubt about it.
Both your test and Mrs. Lloyd's are definitely positive,
and the sooner you start taking a treatment, Mrs. Lloyd, the sooner that baby of yours will be out of danger.
[John:] But doctor.
[Doctor:] Both of you can take a treatment in a few days time and it's an-almost certain cure.
You can receive your treatment either from your family physician,
or you may take it here at the health department.
[Liza:] And my baby?
[Doctor:] When we treat a pregnant woman for syphilis,
her baby receives the same medicine through the blood.
[John:] Are you sure it'll be all right, doctor?
[Doctor:] No cure can be guaranteed at 100 percent. It would have been much better had Mrs. Lloyd
gone to a doctor earlier, as any good doctor would have taken blood tests as a part of his regular care.
Your wife is on her fifth month now, but our chances of curing her
and of saving the baby are still good.
[John:] When do we start, doctor?
[Dr. Tidwell:] The John Lloyds, oh yeah, yeah. I delivered her first baby.
[Doctor:] They want to start right away, so I'll send over the results of the test,
and well, it's been a pretty bad shock to the wife, so...
[Dr. Tidwell:] I understand. Umhmm. Yeah.
[Dr. Tidwell:] Well, Mrs. Lloyd, that's the last treatment.
Of course I'd like to see about every four weeks for a checkup before the baby comes.
I don't think we've got much to worry about.
[Liza:]  And the baby will come normal and...
[Dr. Tidwell:] Look Mrs. Lloyd, we doctors do a great deal sometimes, but we're not magicians.
Thousands of babies die every year, from this and lots of other diseases simply because
women won't see  their doctors during the first month or two of pregnancy.
When they put off coming until much later as you did, we can still do a great deal,
but it makes things a lot harder.
Why did you wait so long?
[Liza:] I thought it was all right, I felt all right.
[Dr. Tidwell:] Exactly, you thought you were all right and yet you, you endangered the life of your own child.
[Liza:] Maybe it ought to die.
[Dr. Tidwell:] Now don't be foolish Liza, there is no reason to get yourself all upset.
Everything's going to work out all right.
[Music]
[John:] Liza, before we get to where we can't talk, I want to tell you how, exactly what happened.
[Liza:] No need to do that, John.
Dr. Tidwell says it's been my fault too, for not coming in to see him.
[John:] I know but Liza it's, it's all my fault, I caused all of it.
[Liza:] Oh John, for heaven's sake, let's go home.
[Mrs. McElvery:] That's right, Dr. Tidwell. Prenatal clinic every other Thursday at 2.
[Dr. Tidwell:] I've asked Mrs. Lloyd to come along too, she's pretty upset about things,
and I'm afraid that if she loses interest in her baby, it might not be so good.
[Mrs. McElvery:] I understand. Of course. Just send her around and we'll take care of her.
Goodbye.
[Music]
[Mrs. McElvery:] Kitty, this is Mrs. Lloyd. This is Kitty Kendrick.
[Liza:] How do you do?
[Kitty:] Glad to meet you.
[Mrs. McElvery:] They're the young couple that lives in the house just beyond you.
[Music]
[Liza:] Let me show you.
[Kitty:] God but you're quick, how many babies have you had?
[Liza:] Just one. But that's enough to teach you how to change diapers.
[Mrs. McElvery:] The trouble with learning on a doll, Kitty, is that a doll can't wiggle.
[Liza:] That's the truth.
[Music]
[Brad:] Hi folks.
[Kitty:] Brad. Come meet John and Liza.
This is Brad.
[Liza:] How are you?
[Brad:] Glad to meet you folks.
[John:] How are you Brad?
[Kitty:] Liza goes to the clinic too, they save me that awful bus ride.
[Brad:] Hope you'll pardon my looks, this heat is about to get me down.
[John:] That's all right, you'll get used to it in a year or so.
[Brad:] Guess I'd better, the heat is so bad out at the plant,
we're putting in a new air conditioning machine.
[Kitty:] Brad, these people have to go home.
Liza has a whole family to cook for.
[Brad:] Oh sure. Sorry folks.
Come see us sometime.
[Kitty:] Yes, please do Liza.
[Liza:] We'll do that. And you people come see us.
We'd love to have you.
[Mama:] It's too hot to eat, much less cook.
[Jeremiah:] August is always the hottest month.
[Liza:] I've got to go put supper on the table now, Kitty.
But call me back later.
And don't worry, you've got months to go yet.
[Jeremiah:] Is them women still talking?
[Mama:] Oh that kid is just fine.
Every time she gets a kick she thinks her time is come.
[Liza:] Kitty says she's buying both pink and blue just to make sure.
[Jeremiah:] Where is John, I'm hungry.
[Liza:] Still out in the chicken house again.
[Jeremiah:] Looks like he's 'bout to go live with those chickens,
the way he sticks out there all the time.
[Liza:] He makes some hay, doesn't he?
If more people around here would work as hard to make things run...
[Jeremiah:] All right, all right. I'll go get him.
[Liza:] No, leave him, papa.
He'll eat with me later, when it's cool.
[Music]
[Liza:] John, what's the matter?
Staying out here night after night.
I know you want to make a go of these chickens,
but you don't have to cut yourself off from everybody.
[John:]  After what I've done to you Liza, I haven't any right...
[Liza:] But John, I don't feel that way.
It was both our faults and besides, we just can't keep on like this.
[John:] And if the baby isn't born right I'd never forgive myself.
[Liza:] But the doctor says it has a good chance.
Don't let this thing get you all twisted up.
Everybody makes mistakes.
[John:]  After what I've done, I haven't any right to a son. I haven't any right to a son at all.
[Mama:] Cry it out. Whatever is bothering you, Liza baby.
[Music and crying]
[Rooster crowing]
[Grandfather:] It works itself.
Never have to touch it.
[Liza:] They're so cute.
[Grandfather:] Spent more than $450 on our last four thousand broilers.
Got another batch coming off next week.
[Mama:] Kitty came over to see Liza off to the hospital,
but looks like the old man's gonna keep her in the chicken house all day.
Jeremiah, we'd better go.
Jeremiah!
[Liza:] Coming.
[Music]
[Jeremiah:] Having babies in the hospital is just plain foolish.
That bed upstairs was good enough for you to have your babies in.
[Mama:] That's before I could [?]... they probably didn't have these treatments.
[Music]
[John paces as the family waits in the hospital waiting room for the baby to be born.]
[John:] Doctor, are you sure you've done everything possible?
[Dr. Tidwell:] I took another blood test just yesterday John, and it looked all right.
I don't think we've got anything special to worry about.
Of course I'll have to check the baby every month for three months after it's born.
[John:] I know Liza's up there suffering to birth a child that won't be right.
Just because of what I did.
It's happened to other people. I have seen those kids, all twisted up.
[Dr. Tidwell:] John, listen to me.
Liza's baby is in far less danger right now than dozens are that are going to be born
in this hospital between now and Christmas, simply because their mothers haven't had blood tests.
If there was just some way we can get women to understand how important these tests are.
[Nurse 2:] Dr. Tidwell, you're wanted in delivery.
[Dr. Tidwell:] Okay. Take it easy John.
[John:] Okay, thanks doctor.
[Music]
[Voice in John's head:] I haven't any right to a son. That baby's in danger of its life.
[Nurses's voice:] Blind, crippled, or dead.
[Dr. Tidwell's voice:] That may be right.
That baby's in danger of its life.
[Distorted voices of the doctor and nurse in the background.]
[Dramatic music]
[Baby crying]
[Female voice:] Date of birth, September 18th, weight 7 pounds 8 ounces.
Sex, male.
Name of parents, John and Liza Lloyd.
Isn't he sweet, John?
He looks just like you.
[John:] Does he?
[Liza:] Pick him up and hold him.
[John:] No, I think I'd better not.
[Liza:] Why not?
[John:] I'd better not just yet.
[Liza:] Oh, John.
[John:] Well, I better be getting back.
It's getting late.
I'll see you tomorrow. Bye.
[Music]
[Dr. Tidwell:] Yes sir, he's one of the finest babies I've ever had the privilege of delivering.
Aren't you boy?
[Liza:] He's growing so fast he'll be answering you back in another month or so.
[Dr. Tidwell:] I want to make a final blood check at the end of the three months.
There's absolutely nothing to worry about, but it's always best to make sure.
[Liza:] All right.
[Music]
[Dr. Tidwell:] You got yourself a prizewinner in this boy, John.
[John:] Thanks doctor.
[Kitty:] Look, Brad, isn't he cute?
He's the sweetest baby.
[Dr. Tidwell:] You're about ready for your examination, Mrs. Kendrick?
[Kitty:] Yes, doctor.
Bradley dear, will you hold my bag?
Wait for me Liza, let's have a milkshake before we go home.
[Liza:] Okay.
[Music]
[Kitty:] Let's go down to the  Merry Maid Dairy.
They make milkshakes that high!
[Liza:] Okay.
[Bradley:] That woman is always hungry.
[John:] They all are about this time.
[Music]
[Patsy:] I'n gonna take it to my room granny.
[Mama:] All right Patsy.
But don't be climbing on things.
[Patsy:] I'm not.
[Mama:] Liza, what's John got against that boy of his?
[Liza:] Nothing that I know of.
Why?
[Mama:] It's not natural the way he's acting.
Don't ever play with this baby like he used to be doing Patsy all the time.
Don't think as much as I've ever seen him pick up the child.
He don't act natural to you, either.
[Liza:] John's got lots on his mind, mama.
He's always asking about the baby.
And besides you can't expect a man to, sshh, here he comes.
[John:] Hey.
[Liza:] Hi.
[John:] Warm enough in here, Liza?
[Liza:] Heavens yes, you've got it hot as an oven in here now.
[John:] I got to get back and get the house cleaned up before dark.
[Liza:] Well, we'll be eating in another hour.
[John:] Okay.
[Music]
[Telephone ringing]
[Mama:] John, John.
[John:] What's the matter?
[Mama:] Kitty's time's coming and not a soul in the house to get her to the hospital.
[Music]
[Liza:] How far apart are the pains now, Kitty?
Well, stay just as quiet as you can. We'll get you there, honey.
[John:] You'll be all right. We'll have you there.
[Kitty:] But Dr. Tidwell said it'd be three weeks!
[John:] Easy now, Kitty, easy.
We'll have you there in no time.
[Brad:] Gee thanks John.
Tell Kitty I'll be there just as quick as I can drive.
[John:] Well, for goodness sake don't kill yourself on the road.
I'll stay here.
Okay.
That's his first one.
[Receptionist:] I know what you mean.
[John:] Better watch out Brad, they're gonna charge you extra for wearing out their floor.
[Brad:] Gosh John.
Something must have gone wrong. Dr. Tidwell said it wouldn't be for three weeks yet.
[John:] But look Brad, I talked to Dr. Tidwell when I brought Kitty in.
You've got a lot less to worry about than Liza and I had when our boy came.
You see Liza didn't go to the doctor right off as soon as she found out she was pregnant,
like Kitty did.
And when she seemed to need me most, I was so tied up with all sorts of things
that I just couldn't seem to help her.
[Brad:] That's my trouble John, I'm off at the plant all day, nobody home.
I don't know how Kitty is going to manage by herself.
[John:] Good Lord Brad, when Kitty gets hold of that baby there'll be me, Liza, Mama Crawford.
Somebody over there all the time.
We'll be over there so much you'll have to start charging us board.
[Delivery nurse:] Mr. Kendrick.
[Brad:] Here ma'am.
[Delivery nurse:] You can come up now.
[John:] I'll see you later, Brad.
[John:] Liza, Liza. It's a girl. Six pounds.
[Liza:] Come already?
[John:] Yeah, Kitty came through it fine, and you should have seen Bradley.
That boy was so excited I thought he'd pop.
He was really something.
[Liza:] I bet he was.
[Music]
[John:] Lordy, he's heavy.
[Liza:] He ought to be, he's almost three months old.
And Dr. Tidwell said he's the healthiest baby in the county.
[John:] He's gettin' big as a young calf.
Do you really think he looks like me, Liza?
[Liza:] He's the spitting image of you, John.
[Music]